all three of you in light of what we've
been talking about and in light of what
director Ray said and I I I think it's
really really important that we we go to
what also was said by secretary mayorcas
yesterday he was asked a very simple
question this question was asked by
Senator Johnson of Wisconsin uh about
how many people have come into this
country illegally watch this
tape your
chair let me see I need numbers I again
don't feel me how many people has this
administration led into the country let
me say at the outset that U our job
would be a lot easier if the broken
immigration system was Mr secretary I
want a number how many people have you
led into this country I I should
also I'll give you the number it's about
six million about 1.7 million as known
Goda alwayss now again we don't know who
these people
are we just know that they've come to
this country and they're residing
somewhere
are we asking too much to you're the
Secretary of Homeland Security the
director of the FBI is saying we have
terror threats that are increasing and
they don't know how many people they've
allowed into the country can you explain
that Sean this is alarming and in fact
if you go under President Obama Jay
Johnson when he was Homeland Security
secretary said a thousand people coming
across was too many we've got millions
that have come across they can't tell
you how many are on the terrorist watch
list some of the countries you talked
about uh places from foreign adversaries
at a time as you see when terror is
getting on the rise this is a major
concern that's why we passed hr2 the
strongest border security package this
group here came together passed a strong
border security package to fix this
problem Joe Biden doesn't want to talk
about it but look this isn't a
Republican or Democrat issues Democrat
Mayors around the country recognize this
is a major problem they're calling on
President Biden to fix this as well I
think the country has come a long way to
recogn izing this is one of the top
issues major threat to our national
security Joe Biden's the only one Mia on
this hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else